look I just started my second company my
third company will be AI girlfriends
no like I mean I want to find out what
your fourth company is oh wow because I
think once you have ai girlfriends it's
uh
oh boy
does it get interesting
well maybe let's go there I mean the
relationships with AI That's creating
human-like organisms right
and part of being human is being
conscious is being having the capacity
to suffer having the capacity to
experience this love richly in such a
way that you can empathize
the AI system is going to empathize with
you and you can empathize with it or you
can project your uh anthropomorphic
sense of what the other entity is
experiencing and and an AI model would
need to
um yeah to create that experience inside
your mind and it doesn't seem that
difficult yeah but okay so here's where
it actually gets totally different right
you interact with another human you can
make some assumptions
yeah when you interact with these models
you can't you can make some assumptions
that that other human experiences
suffering and pleasure in a pretty
similar way to you do the golden rule
applies
with an AI model this isn't really true
right these these large language models
are good at fooling people because they
were trained on a a whole bunch of human
data until to mimic it yep but if if the
AI system says hi my name is Samantha
uh has a backstory yeah I went to
college here and there yeah maybe you'll
integrate this in AI system I made some
chat Bots I give them backstories it was
lots of fun I was so happy when llama
came out yeah well we'll talk about a
lot and we'll talk about all that but
like you know the rock with the smiley
face yeah
why this it seems pretty natural for for
you to anthropomorphize that thing and
then start dating it and before you know
it
you're married and have kids or the rock
or the rock those pictures on Instagram
with you in a rock and smiley face to be
fair like you know something that people
generally look for when they're looking
for someone to date is intelligence and
some
form and The Rock doesn't really have
intelligence only a pretty desperate
person would date a rock
I think we're all desperate deep down oh
not rock level desperate all right uh
uh not rock level
desperate but AI level desperate I don't
know I think all of us have a deep
loneliness it just feels like the
language models are there
oh I agree and you know what I won't
even say this so cynically I will
actually say this in a way that like I
want AI friends I do yeah like I would
love to you know again I the language
models now are still a little like
people are impressed with these GPT
things and I look at like or or like or
uh the the co-pilot the coding one and
I'm like okay this is like Junior
engineer level and these people are like
five or level artists and copywriters
like okay great we got like Fiverr and
like Junior Engineers okay cool like and
this is just a start and it will get
better right like I would I can't wait
to have ai friends who are more
intelligent than I am so Fiverr is just
a temporary it's not the ceiling no
definitely not
is it uh is it count as cheating
when you're talking to an AI model
emotional cheating
that's that's up to you and your human
partner to Define oh you have to all
right you can yeah you have to have that
have to have that conversation I guess
all right I mean integrate that with uh
with porn and all this well I don't know
I mean a similar kind of porn yeah yeah
right I think people in relationships
have different views on that
yeah but most people don't have
like
serious open conversations about
all the different aspects of what's cool
and what's not
and it feels like AI is a really weird
conversation to have
the porn one is a good branching off
sure like these things you know one of
my scenarios that I put in my chatbot is
I uh you know uh
a nice girl named Lexi she's 20 she just
moved out to LA she wanted to be an
actress but she started doing only fans
instead and you're on a date with her
enjoy
oh man yeah and so was that if you're
actually dating somebody in real life is
that cheating
I feel like it gets a little weird sure
it gets real weird it's like what are
you allowed to say to an AI bot imagine
having that conversation with a
significant other I mean these are all
things for people to Define in their
relationships what it means to be human
is just gonna start to get weird let's
pushing it online like how do you know
like there'll be moments when you'll
have what you think is a real human you
interacted with on Twitter for years and
you realize it's not
I spread I love this meme uh Heaven
Banning do you know what shadow Banning
yeah right Shadow Banning okay you post
no one can see it Heaven Banning you
post no one can see it but a whole lot
of AIS are spun up to interact with you
well maybe that's what the way human
civilization ends is all of us a heaven
banned there's a great uh it's called My
Little Pony Friendship is optimal it's a
Sci-Fi story that uh explores this idea
friendship is optimal friendship is
optimal yeah I'd like to have some at
least stuff on the intellectual realm
some AI friends that argue with me
but the the Romantic realm is weird
definitely weird
but
not out of the realm of uh the uh the
kind of weirdness that the human
civilization is capable of I think
I want it look I want it if no one else
wants it I want it yeah I think a lot of
people probably want it there's a deep
loneliness
and I'll fill there loneliness and you
know it just will only advertise to you
some of the time yeah maybe the
conceptions of monogamy change too like
I grew up in a time like I value
monogamy but maybe that's a silly notion
when you have
arbitrary number of AI systems
um this this um this interesting path
from rationality to polyamory yeah that
doesn't make sense for me for you but
you're just a biological organism it was
born before
like read the internet really took off
the crazy thing is like culture is
whatever we Define it as right these
things are not you like is a lot problem
and moral philosophy right there's no
like like okay what is might be that
like computers are capable of mimicking
uh you know girlfriends perfectly they
pass the girlfriend turning test right
but that doesn't say anything about a
lot that doesn't say anything about how
we ought to respond to them as a
civilization that doesn't say we ought
to get rid of monogamy right that's a
completely separate question really a
religious one
girlfriend touring test I wonder what
that looks like girlfriend are you
writing that
uh will you be the the the Alan touring
of the 21st century that writes the uh
the girlfriend touring testimony I mean
of course my my hey our girlfriends
their goal is to pass the girlfriend
Turing test
no but you there should be like a paper
that kind of defines the test or I mean
the question is if it's deeply
personalized or there's a common thing
that really gets
everybody
yeah I mean you know look we're a
company we don't get everybody we just
have to get a large enough uh clientele
today I thought you already already
thinking company